all right Mike you got a big smile on
your face
what are you doing here just here to
hang out with you uh-huh
that's up are you the bachelor I have no
idea
well why are you doing an interview with
me today talk about bachelor in paradise
okay I just wonder if maybe you were
like in town like having some talks
about being The Bachelor not at all not
at all
0% no talk is about being The Bachelor
Zera really really okay cuz a lot of
people are excited about the idea of you
potentially being the first black
bachelor I'll be the first black
bachelor I'll be the first bachelor
that's a veteran I'll be the first Mike
Johnson
so yeah it's more than just being the
first black bachelor well look you're a
super charismatic guy people are
attracted to this big smile you're
giving me right now I gotta say you know
I mean bachelor usually starts filming
around mid-september we have had
bachelors kind of pop off from Paradise
before so is this still a possibility
by the way Derrick was actually getting
a little bachelor love after everything
with Demi yeah wait till you watch
tonight okay you never know what might
happen he might be back with Demi he
might not
we never know we never know okay well
I'm not pulling the strings here would
you be the bachelor if that was offered
to you before you know the time came if
you're single I was waiting for I'm like
am i single cuz like I don't cheat so
therefore I got to be single and if I
was single would I be the bachelor like
I told you last time it has conversation
had to take place okay one you know
country music is cool but like I like
R&B okay so we got to have some R&B
music if I were to be devatha oh okay
I was gonna ask what would the vibe be
on a Mike Johnson bachelor season it's
sexy sensual or not the whole season
we're like someday we just came up
windmills sexy and sensual okay that is
that is definitely true that's
definitely true well it would be a
milestone I mean we've had a black
Bachelorette Rachel Lindsay correct um
have you spoken to Rachel about that at
all about the potential and about what
that would be like for you originally
and I have had conversations when I'd
rather
just about two people both from Dallas
originally both on the show and we have
a mutual friend which is kind of cool
okay yeah did she give you any advice
about all this what she said her and
Jason tarts both told me to simply be
the man that my mom told me to be and
that's exactly what I'm gonna do
so you're on paradise right now I am are
you single
I don't know you gotta watch what kind
of woman are you looking for the woman
that I may or may not be what right now
and the woman that will marry is going
to I like fierce I like little attitude
like I love Demi's little attitude at
times she could be a little bit much
sometimes but I love her little fierce
attitude I like a woman that can teach
me I want to grow I'm always trying to
learn something
yeah I want a woman that's fierce
someone that you know can teach me a
woman that is goofy wants to travel the
world open to new experiences sexual has
spirituality yeah all those things okay
so it's actually getting Mike I think
we'd get a sexy season with you maybe
it's a part of life on me come on I saw
your tweet the other day what you see is
this isn't like I just want somebody who
I can like send some freaky text to yeah
okay how freaky are the texts that you
might or may not be sending it depends
on our relationship you know it depends
on how deep we are okay you're okay with
a freaky moment yeah yeah I gotta be
married forever like 50-plus years so
you know we got to change up some things
every now I like it too yeah I also
wanted to ask you
speaking of keeping a little flirty Miss
Hannah brown posted this Instagram photo
of herself and it had like kind of like
I said like a little table in it and you
come into something like girl girl it
was sexy it was a little on her boob
hanging it was nice it was a sexy
picture there's some chemistry here no
no no no feelings for Hannah no no
chemistry
no I just I care about her
person is a good friend I want to ask
you about some of the other drama you
mentioned miss Demi so Demi and Tanner
got into a Twitter war dummy and Tanner
Tolbert he compared her to Jed Wyatt
okay he accused her of going on to
paradise with a plan to be with someone
at the end of all of it what did you
think of all that I think that's a very
good question asked because you're gonna
get some juice so kudos for you I think
that Jed didn't reveal that he has
someone back home until the very end and
I think that Demi revealed that she had
feelings and she who had been dating
someone and told that to Derick in the
beginning so it's different mm-hmm I do
think though it's different so she was
that friend about it that she yeah she
was upfront well we actually did a phone
interview with Tanner and he kind of
expounded on it and he said look maybe
Jed was the furthest comparison I could
have gone to maybe I should have
compared her to Blake and Hanna and that
they came into paradise with kind of an
agenda with having flirted with each
other before and he was just frustrated
he feels like on this season of paradise
a lot of people are coming in with other
relationships already and he feels like
it all should happen on the beach so
what do you think about that I mean if I
could talk to Tanner I'm like homie it's
2019 people have cell phones people DM
each other and text each other and
sliding you chose deems and nothing no
one could do about that
I personally speaking of me myself
wasn't trying to get with someone and
then see them on the beach and that's
what I'm gonna stick to yeah is me
myself well you can sign to people's DMS
you can attend stagecoach and meet
67,000 people you can blade I don't know
why you came on the show is that how you
feel how I feel about Blake is that
hopefully he learns from this experience
that's how I feel sounds like you don't
love Blake's action
I think it was immature even if you are
single you sleep multiple people cool no
big deal that's your thing but to do
that with girls that are going to be
able paradise and you're going to
paradise that's where the I think that's
the that was kind of an issue it was
interesting he seemed so shocked that
everything was going so wrong for him
it's kind of thinking like what you
expect you know during paradise I was
just literally have my little happy
juice yeah as we call it the Chardonnay
and Red Bull oh and I will walk off like
what combination it's delicious sure
named Red Bull this delicious okay Blake
look you went on a date with Kaylin um
that doesn't seem to have worked out
she's she moves on with Dean on the show
we've seen that but like Kaitlyn and
Blake had all this drama and it seems
like she was a person who you cared
about
he ended up hosting text messages
there's two of them what did you think
of that move I don't read the text
messages at all I don't want to know
what they have what they did I think
about that move it was his way of trying
to defend himself but I didn't read the
text messages so I don't know what they
say okay how is the cast feeling about
it overall I mean obviously you guys
form relationships and probably keep
talking once filming is over what was
the general reaction to the text posting
I
that's a great question as well I think
the cast feels whoever's on Blake side
is gonna stay on inside who's ever now
on Blake sides want to continue to not
be on his side it's all that dividing
the cast a little bit no I think our
cast is pretty strong and they're
strong-willed Nate they're just like me
i'ma believing what I believe in yeah
and for me Mike Johnson I didn't pay
attention to none of it because I don't
want to be a part of any of that drama
well cuz we saw like I think Dean went
on a podcast and he called it
slut-shaming but Christina on Instagram
posted some support to Blake so it
seemed like people have different
opinions on see I saw Dean say slushie
anybody and you see what Christina had
posted
I literally tries to half it you just
send it for
to tax you're busy yeah I'm just saying
for you text if I could Monday night on
bachelor
we've been teased the biggest white in
bachelor in paradise history how wild is
this physical fight get let's just say
get your popcorn ready for tonight okay
definitely so I mean I didn't expect it
to be Jordan getting in a fight with
somebody how like Jordan the guy in the
gold underwear he's the one who gets in
a fight do you not hear Jordan he's just
talks he's like a little chihuahua just
barking okay that's fair but how does he
do does he like hold up against this guy
in a fight well Christian is suave and
Jordan is a model but I don't consider
him a model he's like well I mean and
this let's talk about this right let's
talk about it okay you can I am NOT a
model alright I just take pictures with
photographers just because someone else
takes pictures with photographer doesn't
make them a model right so your calendar
and not on that no I'm just saying
Christian is suave and Jordan is not a
model he's more rambunctious right and
so he handles himself well Jordan does
yes who would you say is the winner in
this fight come on y'all leave a
cliffhanger like for you guys in the
moment when you see this breaking out
what's going through everybody's mind is
your jaw dropping yeah so you know the
crime of the frog emoji yeah girl over
there yeah I was definitely mmm-hmm you
went on a date with Kailyn she then
seems to gravitate towards Dean yes
was that hurtful for you I think that
when I go on a date with someone that
she goes on a date with someone else
it's a very nice day it's like Daniel do
I suck but at the same time my
confidence is on ten because not
everyone's meant for everyone
mm-hmm that's or indeed seem to have a
lot of chemistry do you do you think and
she said she'd been attracted to him for
a long time yeah do you think they knew
each other a little bit
paradise no idea I know that I bet you
do now if I do not you won't find out I
have I know that she did mention that
she liked him for a very long time okay
I mean were you surprised did you think
you and Kailyn had something I don't
know I mean yeah we just have one day it
wasn't great we do have one day you were
really good I think that her lips curl
and coil and I think that's sexy and
that's really about it well a lot of
people have been talking about Dean
having a bit of a transformation you
know last summer he was the bad boy he
was the player of paradise do you think
Blake's really taken that title from
Dean like damn sure is if anybody were
to get the title of player I would give
it to Blake does he deserve it Kevin
made a comment like he's not even that
good-looking
Kevin Zoey um I would say that Blake is
not the best-looking guy on the show but
I'm not the best-looking guy on the show
all right so I think dealing with a five
o'clock shadow if Dylan does not have a
five o'clock shadow it is not dealing
but if Dylan has this five o'clock
shadow is Dylan doing a Nana are I mean
they're in it now but a lot of people
have been like breaking down her facial
expressions wondering if she's as into
him as he's into her and then some of
the women have said Hannah's
manipulating in a situation what do you
think about that I think that Hanna she
is so freaking sweet like really genius
like she's a incredibly sweet girl
and I feel that for some people it's
hard to hurt someone's feelings and
she's growing on camera on how to walk
through letting someone down
I gotta go back to the bachelor
possibility a little bit I feel like
some people are almost hoping you don't
find love and paradise because they want
you to be the bachelor yeah how do you
feel I've gotten a lot of comments about
like damn the point of going on bachelor
series is if I love right I just want to
find love I hope that people if Paradise
is where I have found my love I hope
that people are happy for that I think
that all of us include myself have some
type of some form of selfishness and
people have you know cleaned onto me and
want me to be the first veteran black
bachelor ever which is freaking awesome
but for me in my heart I just want to
find love and I hope that people realize
that other candidates for Bachelor have
been Peter Webber he's been thrown out
of course Tyler Tyler seems to be a
little busy with gigi hadid have you
talked to Tyler how is he
tom is happy Holly's good Tyler is a
pissing me off because like he can eat
cookies and eat all this fat food and
still have a better body to me when you
say he's happy to me like he's happily
in a relationship with a supermodel that
I don't know have you talked to him
lately I have and what is he saying how
is he doing he's good
I don't I don't ask him about his
relationship status really I don't
Mike how do you not asking about yo
you're hanging out with gigi hadid how's
that going
I think that she's a person beautiful
person yeah she's beautiful she is but I
what I talked to him about is bro what
are you doing like how are you getting
your abs do you think that Tyler would
be the bachelor if that was offered to
him or is he kind of in a relationship
right now I think that the bachelor like
I said I think I told you before I think
the bachelor will be Peter you think you
think that why based on history repeats
itself I think that Peter looks the part
I think that Peter when he has a five
o'clock shadow Peter looks good too I
love your support for five oclock
shadows Mike yeah you know five o'clock
shadow that's what the world needs to be
I think that Peters family is
I mean I've hung out with his brother
he's awesome his mom you know they got a
little Spanish flair I think that Peter
and his family is great so you support
Peter for bachelor
if I were she was a bachelor it'll be
Peter okay yeah
so when you say history repeats itself
what do you mean they have like a
similar look and I think that Peter
looks like he could be the bachelor he
looks like him and Nick Viall that's
what I'm saying it
there was an Instagram post and it was
like identical Nick Viall ten years ago
looks identical to Peter okay and so
just from what looks wise that's all
we're talking about you potentially
being the first black bachelor we don't
say history repeats itself he looks like
the other bachelors that makes me think
another white bachelor and that's that's
perfectly fine I wasn't thinking that
yeah I just think that he literally
looks like Nate bio I think it looks
like Nick and Ben Higgins his baby
probably they shouldn't they should make
it they should make that happen
so you think Peter would be how is a
bachelor a good bachelor I think Peter
will be a good bachelor I think that he
would be a safe bachelor meaning that he
won't do anything crazy obnoxious I
think that'll be a good safe clean
season if he were to be bachelor okay a
safe clean season yes you were promising
it's a sexy sensual season a minute ago
that's if I was a bachelor okay so
Peters gonna be safe clean he is gonna
be saving clean cuz he has condoms and
he keeps them in his car yeah he was the
window guy though he was and he went
four times hey that's one boy okay well
maybe sexier and Peter's not sexier than
I am you know speaking of Tyler dating
Gigi indeed you had a potential
celebrity relationship Demi Lovato was
interested in you oh nothing nothing
I won't paradise okay but like Hannah
told me yeah if I wanted to I could I
could introduce them she hung out with
Demi
so where was Hannah Hannah Hannah what's
up Trevor I say no I think that Hannah
respects what I have going on paradise
okay so if you're single at the end of
paradise are you gonna say Hanna can you
put me on a group text with demi lovato
now please that's a possibility but I'm
focused on it they're here and now okay
you I mean we got a lot of Paradise
drama but you wound up in a bit of a
social media confrontation
not long ago as someone came after you
and said well that's comments if
somebody said you don't like women of
color yes and you responded to that I
did how did that make you feel why did
you want to respond to that comment I
didn't like that comedy because all my
queens are women of color and I adore
them in my dating history I've dated
women of color and that was just
complete ignorance period and I don't
like that I'm not gonna represent you
and especially when you call me out
specifically yeah you see how my
demeanor changes I'm like hell no we're
not doing that like oh I like women of
all colors but it's gonna be your
personality that attracts me mm-hmm
I mean look you guys have a lot of
followers you something like five
hundred thousand if not more followers I
would imagine you get some horrible
comments yeah and you can't respond to
all of them prick but with that when it
seems like you thought no I'm driving
here correct I mean I don't look at all
of them right and just literally get me
scrolling in like oh that's BS I'm gonna
talk to you right quick and don't nobody
say I should be as she's talking respond
because I'm not whatever you know but to
give you what you're asking I adore and
love women of color I mean I'm a man of
color I'm a black man I'm proud of you a
black man and I have no problem dating a
black woman a Asian woman a Mexican
woman a white woman if she was green
I'll definitely check her out
I really would because I'm like oh
you're barren
let me let me highlight you okay
appearance divulging from the norm
here's the thing you have the Big Mike
smile but then we've seen like with Luke
P we've seen when you you can turn and
you you get serious 100%
I always like try I like to might call
out you would really call the shot on a
situation 100% yeah that's why sexy
sensual real did you get into any more
drama yourself in paradise you really
think I would tell you that why do you
think I will tease that the first think
anyone my was the most dramatic season
ever we're gonna get a really emotional
storyline
I think continually with Demi I mean
she's spoken to Derek about her having
feelings for this woman
um how she's confused she's talked about
coming out to her parents and all these
really big things on the show what was
that like for you guys to be a part of
in terms of Demi's journey and kind of
knowing that this was sort of the first
queer relationship coming to the
forefront on a bachelor show for me
personally I didn't think of it being a
person of same sex my thought was to
immediately console Derek because I know
that he really likes Demi and to have
that situation occur I wanted to be
there for Derek yeah I know that the
majority of the cast wanted to be there
for Demi and I wanted to be there for
Dimmie as well but I just felt that no
one would be there for Derek and so I
wanted to consult Derek Derek has been
pretty selfless and lovely in this whole
situation and Emmys applauded him on
Twitter saying how amazing he is it
seems like a lot was thrown at him and
he really handled it really well that's
the homie how emotional do things get
for Demi and Derek that I have no
problem saying and it's a moment of ice
cream and tears I would say that
definitely said were you guys affected
by it there on the beach I mean Demi
going through all this and talking about
it Derek like how did their emotions
translate onto everybody else
quite honestly I'm just focused on my
left side yeah it really affect me and I
personally could care less if they're
same-sex opposite sex
they don't matter to me was 2019 like
love somebody somebody's green hey if
she's green I like baby let's go to the
doctor first make sure you healthy
you healthy cool let's just do it how do
I just ask you one more question about
the bachelor possibility and Rachel
Lindsay talked a lot about sort of the
backlash that she did get from some
people horribly for being the first
black Bachelorette she's spoken about
all these things would you feel a
pressure in being the first black
bachelor how would you kind of prep
yourself for that if it would happen
prior to going on bachelor in paradise
and prior to the situation that I'm in
now ie whether single or not single
after coming off of the Bachelorette
Season that was bombarded with me and I
was just considered still thinking like
dude like Hannah just you know broke oh
I mean I can I grieve for a moment but
then there are times when I have felt
pressure I'm not gonna live I felt
pressure I'm human being people and the
pressure came from to be the first
anything you're gonna get scrutinized
for every little thing like I've seen on
my in some of the comments oh he's too
nice did you not just see me call Luke
out like really and then some people
said to me right and then some people
say oh he has tattoos and I really don't
care about none of that stuff like I'm
me oh well and so I had a little bit of
pressure about that but the the pressure
I really did have was around colorism
and racism
I felt that I would get pressure from
certain people's in one group and
certain people's in another group and
what has to help me get over that is
just I have a good supporting cast my
little sister she's amazing and she'll
cut somebody off in a heartbeat and then
my homeboys they're just like yo just
fine love ya you know I'm not gonna
please everybody so I think that I'm a
leader and to be a leader you're not
gonna please everybody
I'm not everyone's best friend alright
last question for you especially after
an Instagram post from the Dancing with
the Stars account a lot of people saying
Hannah is
I'm Dancing with the Stars okay here
we've seen some of her moves how do you
think she do should be great
Shanna is a little clumsy i coli and I'm
sorry
she look clumsy but Hannah is she's a
very competitive person Hannah she's
extremely competitive and I think that
she'll give it her all and she
definitely will bust her lot in practice
[Laughter]
be an audience I'll be her number one
fan
yeah do you want to move forward maybe
giving her some tips baby I'm saying
torqued it back a little bit more right
there you know if their arms up a little
bit there you go
[Music]